welcome back to the David Pakman show
Benjamin Dixon filling in for David
David is away in Los Angeles appearing
on the Joe Rogan podcast so I'm sure
that's gonna be a great conversation
glad to be here with you today go over
to the Benjamin diction's show on
YouTube and subscribe new content is up
and it's my birthday so you know help me
get over 25,000 subscribers but anyway
let's get to the news everything
conservatives do trying to attack
Alexandria Acacio Cortes instantly turns
into a commercial for her there's a
tweet by a guy Ryan Saavedra
he works for Ben Shapiro's daily wire
and he tweeted this out there's two
parts I'm gonna read the tweet first and
then I want you to watch the video the
video is a little difficult to hear but
it's worth watching this is what he said
on Twitter quote Socialist
Representative Alexandria Acacio Cortes
of Democratic New York on her 93
trillion Green Deal green New Deal quote
you have the right to a job you have the
right to an education you have the right
to health care a right to a dignified
home and a right to a dignified
retirement let's take a listen into that
clip so here's the thing I find it
hilarious that every single thing
Republicans think is going to be a
turn-off about Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
instantly becomes a turn-on
in terms of politics and her political
stance I want to make sure that was
clear what I'm talking about there but
seriously do you think anyone looking at
this except a sadist would look at this
and say oh this is just something that
we absolutely don't want these are
things that we don't want know if anyone
has a problem with having a right to a
job a right to an education a right to
health care and a right to a dignified
home housing and a right to a dignified
retirement all of those things are
really a part of what the American dream
always was particularly for baby boomers
the baby boomer generation these things
were expected a job a decent job a
decent education so anyone who looks at
that and has a problem with it is really
quite sadistic number one but number two
the only question that should be asked
about this is how do we pay for it not
in this Republican way they're like oh
how are we going to get this done but if
there's any question is how do we pay
for it and then you look at where we're
doing all of the spending we're
currently doing particularly on all of
all of our wars on the defense
contractors all the money that is wasted
in our economy already without even
raising taxes on the wealthy any more
than it currently is there's enough
money that's being wasted for us to take
care of all of these things
notwithstanding the fact that we
absolutely should raise taxes on the
wealthiest people in this country not
just because Donald Trump just lowered
them but because they were already
historically low those are the ways that
we pay for these things that's how we
get these things done and and and and
the emphasis that he puts if you don't
mind putting the tweet back on the
screen from Ryan from The Daily wire he
said Socialist Representative Alexandria
Acacio Cortes first of all breath you're
not scaring anyone away with the word
socialist anymore
you guys kind of you know you guys jump
the shark with that with Obama when
every other sentence was a socialist
MAOIs Leninist communist Obama turns out
everybody did well all the capitalists
did well under Barack Obama because
Barack Obama was not a socialist Barack
Obama was a capitalist but because you
guys overplayed that card so much nobody
looks at this and says oh my goodness
she's a socialist and these are
terrifying things
that's number one nobody's afraid of a
socialist anymore thank you for that by
the way but number two nothing that she
says here is remotely socialism in the
way that they're trying to promote it as
socialism I am pretty sure I've had this
conversation with this audience before
but let me emphasize something Bernie
Sanders in Alexandria Acacio Cortes are
not socially
they are at best post office socialists
they are FDR style capitalists they are
trying to save capitalism from itself if
you want to meet some real socialists
let me introduce you to some of my
friends who are like so far to the left
of me that they scare me right there's
actual communists in the country who
want to seize the mean of production
means of production right away you know
like like gulags and guilt guilt things
right away Bernie Sanders and the green
New Deal and Alexandria Kyle Cortez this
is nothing more than post office
socialism where we take a few tax
dollars and we put it together so that
we could do something for the common
welfare to promote the general welfare
goodness right if if you like
firefighters then you are a socialist
according to Republicans right if you
like public schools then you're a
socialist according to Republicans
that's because they have a fetish
they feta sighs privatization of
everything that is their solution to
everything not because they think it's
going to make it better but because they
know that they can make a profit off of
it and they know they can take those
taxes it's not as though they want the
government to not collect the tax
dollars that is currently collecting not
not not the enterprising capitalist not
not these not the well I was gonna say
new capitalist but they've been doing
this for hundreds of years but what they
want as are those tax dollars to be paid
to private industry so private industry
can do the same thing the government
would do but charge a little bit more
and make a profit off of it that's what
they want right so they are socialists
they just want socialism going to the
wealthy not going to the poor and so
what they do is they use a scare tactic
and say oh oh because she believes
Alexandria cosmo Cortese believes that
everyone has a right to a job oh she
wants to turn America into Venezuela
right Acacio Cortez thinks everyone has
a right to health care Oh
Venezuela never mind the fact that
what's going on in Venezuela is not even
the result of socialism as much
it is a result of Americans sanctions
and a result of the swings and oil
prices because Venezuela was
overwhelmingly dependent on oil but I
digress they use that as a scare tactic
so that you can never ever demand more
from this country based on what we're
putting into this country and based on
what the wealthiest people in this
country should be putting in they scare
you with socialism Venezuela warming a
dignified retirement is socialism and
Venezuela and Acacio cortez is a
socialist these are the games that the
Republicans have been playing for years
and and we're finally at it finally at a
tipping point where people are not
terrified by those terms anymore no one
is going to look at a socialist and be
like oh this is the most terrifying
thing that I've ever seen and thank
thanks in part to yes Bernie Sanders
being very consistent over the last I
don't know 30 40 50 60 70 years of his
career love you Bernie and and thanks in
part also to Republicans using that term
over and over and over again and now
people are like well you know what if
the post office is socialism to you then
I'm okay with post office socialism and
we should go one step further and we
should have a nationalized health care
system right a single-payer medicare
medicare for all go even further like we
should have a right to a job that it is
it is very we are we are the wealthiest
country in the history of the world
there's no reason why we cannot get
every person in this country a job and
what last but not least here's here's a
the the the disgusting part about it is
that every single one of these things of
the right to a job the right to an
education right to health care right to
a dignified home and right to a
dignified retirement every single one of
those things based on how America
currently is if we gave every American
one of those things private industry
would benefit private industry would get
the spoils of all of these benefits that
we're giving to individuals it will
absolutely trickle up to private
industry but that's not good enough for
Republicans that's not good enough for
capitalists they don't want to profit
off of your well-being they want to take
the last die
and suck every penny out of your life
and out of your soul they are vultures
that's the irony of this is that we
actually could all do well but they
don't want that they would rather they
do well and well you just uh good luck